boa noite
é muito bom estar aqui numa arena né
o teatro desde que existe a humanidade
ele existe no ser humano
o teatro é a nossa troca né é um olho no
olho
o teatro é o que nos dá a possibilidade
de encontrar o outro
o teatro nos faz dizer aquilo que nós
mesmos não sabemos que está dentro da
gente
quando decidi fazer teatro com 12 anos
de idade e uma menina curiosa queria
muito por conta de uma greve numa escola
estadual néné normal greve escola
estadual no nosso país biblioteca
barulho gritaria gente falando batuque
nossa alguma coisa está acontecendo
nessa sala né
abri a porta e algo mágico estava
acontecendo realmente muitos jovens
muitas crianças estavam em cena
contando uma história e era uma história
de william shakespeare um pedacinho da
peça comédia dos erros e aí eu falei
isso daí que eu quero fazer um negócio
interessante gostei e à leitura também
só que naquela época no interior não
tinha livre de teatro aliás livre de
teatro é difícil até hoje né
há uns 10 anos atrás era muito difícil
então nós vamos na unicamp
pegava aquela máquina velha do pai da
mãe e fotografava as páginas rezava para
não queimar o filme iria e aí eu falei
mas tem alguma coisa errada tá faltando
palavra nesse teatro que eu tô vendo
tudo muito muito fácil tá tudo muito
bonito aqui no interior tudo é muito
ligado à televisão parece que eles
querem copiar novela e não quero ver
novela no palco e foi aí que surgiu a
vontade de ter um grupo de teatro
vamos fazer um grupo de teatro
vamos construir uma estrofe uma história
uma trajetória
vamos buscar a palavra das pessoas levar
pau
a troca com o outro isso não acontecia
tinha uma parede as pessoas não se
relacionavam com aquele teatro era algo
distante
e aí começaram as apresentações do grupo
surgiu em contato com outros grupos nós
fomos descobrindo novas formas de contar
histórias de falar sobre as pessoas e
nós tivemos a ditadura né só pode tá
dura mas muita gente aqui viveu a
ditadura militar no brasil e essa
ditadura nos tirou o direito de falar o
que queria
aí eu falei ah ah ah por isso que falta
a palavra nesse teatro que eu tô vendo
nós não temos mais aqueles que falam o
que pensam
eram poucos muito poucos tudo muito
subjetivo escondido ali e depois de 1990
começou a surgir um movimento em são
paulo e eles começaram com o teatro de
grupo
neste ato de grupo foi se fortalecendo e
foram surgindo novos dramaturgos
dramaturgo são os caras que escrevem
esse teatro que escrevem a história de
um país e um povo né
e então essas pessoas começaram a olhar
para a sociedade que nós estamos
inseridos e fala assim não aqui tem um
tem algo que eu preciso dizer pra você
eu preciso te falar sobre isso você não
está vendo você não não está conseguindo
enxergar esse buraco
a gente precisa tocar de alguma maneira
e ea maneira que encontrei de mudar o
mundo foi tirar um pouquinho as pessoas
da cadeira do sofá da da questão
confortável dia não tem não sei
a inapa são paulo não que são paulo aqui
tem ali do lado tem toda a região que a
gente se encontra tem pessoas lá no
nordeste tem grupos de pessoas ou 10
pequenos maravilhosos de teatro que
escrevem que cantam que são palhaços e
que eles têm essa cultura de nós vamos
tocar a nossa sociedade
o teatro lhe servia pra isso na grécia
antiga ele falava com o povo né
ele era em arena porque você tinha todos
os pontos de vista
eu não tenho um único ponto de vista eu
tenho vários
cada um de vocês vai interpretar o que
eu estou dizendo da sua maneira
porque você tem uma experiência ela tem
outro ele tem outro então a experiência
que eu tenho vai dizer como é que eu vou
interpretar o que eu vejo o que eu vivo
e esse teatro que surgiu agora esses
novos dramaturgos
eles têm essa essa maneira de delapidar
a arte
eu não falo mais daquilo que eu acho eu
falo daquilo que toca qualquer um de
vocês
da maneira que você pudesse ser tocado
por cada